♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden on Thursday
signed his $1.9 trillion
coronavirus relief bill
into law and,
if you're wondering
what Americans
are going to spend it on --
overdraft fees!
During President Biden's
prime time address
on Thursday night,
Fox News aired
a live Tucker Carlson
reaction shot,
though, still not as weird
as when they aired
a President Trump reaction shot
to President Trump.
That's right,
during President Biden's
prime time address,
Fox News aired
a live Tucker Carlson
reaction shot,
I guess to make him
seem like a tough guy,
but, really, it made him
come off like a nosy neighbor.
All it was missing was
a set of Venetian blinds.
[ As Carlton ]
Honey, come here.
Joe's talking
about empathy again.
President Biden today kicked off
his so-called
Help is Here campaign
to promote his new $1.9 trillion
coronavirus relief bill,
though I don't really know
if a bill
giving out $1,400 to people
really needs promotion.
You don't need to promote
something everyone
already loves.
It's why you never see
commercials for sriracha.
The House of Representatives
voted last week
to require background checks
for all gun purchases.
It's the kind of commonsense,
broadly popular proposal
that can't possibly succeed.
So last night was the Grammys
and I wanted to do
a whole piece about it,
but we ran out of time.
-Well, how much time do we have?
-One minute.
-Well, that's all the time
I need.
-Both:
Start the clock.
First of all, the Grammys peaked
before they even started
because Beyoncé's daughter
Blue Ivy won one
for "Brown Skin Girl"!
You remember how she was all
on the song, singing --
♪ Brown skin girl ♪
like a little baby?
It's so cute!
She is perfect.
I love her and I'm right!
-48 seconds!
-Okay, Harry Styles performed
in a leather suit and a boa
and I was like,
"Why do I always want to wear
what Harry Styles wears?
Am I okay?"
Lizzo and Megan Thee Stallion
were adorable.
Bruno Mars and Anderson .Paak
performed the only song
I have been listening to
for ten! days! straight!
Then, for the first time,
all the nominees
for Best Country Album
were women
and I assume one of them won!
-30 seconds!
-Then, when The Strokes
won their Grammy,
they accepted it over Zoom
and they were like,
"Who won?
It keeps cutting out.
Who won?"
And then, someone told them
and they were like, "Yeah!"
Then, Beyoncé won
her 28th Grammy,
making her the most decorated
woman or singer
in Grammy history.
-You're going to run
out of time!
-I can make it!
So, even though she's never won
for Record of the Year...
-10!
-...they only give her Grammys
for half the time she deserves
and she is still
crushing people!
Do you know
that she is the best
and she deserves more Grammys
than she has?
Well, now, you do.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Snaps fingers ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.
[ Laughter ]
Are you going to stay there
for the rest of monologue?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I'm going to stay here.
-According to a new report,
a dog rescue charity
that has ties
to former President Trump's
daughter-in-law Lara
has spent almost $2 million
at Trump properties
over the last seven years.
Wow!
What is it with her and rescues?
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
reportedly thought Meghan Markle
was "no good" after watching
her interview with Oprah,
but declined to say so publicly
out of fear of being cancelled.
[ Laughing ] Dude, I don't know
how to tell you this,
but you were cancelled.
You're not president anymore.
You don't have
a Twitter account.
We can't even find out what you
think about Meghan Markle
until like a week
after everybody else
stopped talking about it.
Can't wait to hear your
thoughts on "WandaVision."
[ As Trump ]
I was confused.
[ Laughter ]
The whole time.
Vice President Kamala Harris
virtually appeared
at this weekend's
Nickelodeon Kids' Choice Awards,
as opposed to our
last vice president,
who doesn't believe
that kids are a choice.
According to a new survey,
the average single person
will masturbate
three times per day,
due to coronavirus-related
quarantines and lockdowns.
Three times a day?!
Where was this survey taken,
at the primate house?
[ Laughter ]
An ice cream company
has released a new flavor,
inspired by the sitcom
"Friends,"
called
Central Perk almond fudge.
It's the first-ever
all-vanilla fudge.
The Ken doll, last week,
turned 60 years old.
He's still smooth down there,
but, now, it doesn't
bother him so much.
"I'm fine, just watching golf."
[ Laughter ]
That means
that somebody else has
to masturbate six times,
to make up for Ken...
[ Laughter ]
...based on this new average
I'm hearing so much about.
Finally,
according to new CDC data,
women are expected to outlive
men by five years nationwide.
Said men, "Weird!
Who bets I can't lick
this ceiling fan?"
♪♪
President Biden said yesterday
that the country was on track
to administer over 100 million
vaccine doses
and send 100 million stimulus
checks in the next 10 days.
But don't forget, by this point
in his presidency,
the last guy completed
almost 100 million putts.
[ As Trump ]
99 million.
I think you guys overcounted.
Vice President Kamala Harris
traveled to Colorado today
to promote the coronavirus
relief package
and visited a vaccination clinic
and a restaurant.
Hopefully, in that order.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Ron Johnson
said,
in an interview last week,
that he was not concerned
for his safety
during January's Capitol attack.
Well, yeah,
you're all Trump guys.
That's like a bird saying it
wasn't concerned for its safety
in "The Birds."
[ Laughter ]
"Birds" ref!
According to a new poll,
a majority of Iowans
do not want 87-year-old
Iowa senator Chuck Grassley
to seek reelection next year,
though many Iowans are cool
with whatever keeps him
off the roads.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
was recently seen
boarding a 24-year-old
midsize private plane
for his recent trip to New York
and, if there's one thing
New York already has plenty of,
it's terrible jets.
[ Laughter ]
Tesla announced yesterday
that CEO Elon Musk
changed his name at the company
to the Technoking of Tesla
and, if you're wondering why
he's so insufferable --
he has a Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
The New York Post published
an article over the weekend
titled,
"In the age of sexual
harassment claims,
is the office romance dead?"
You know, when you ask
a question like that,
you're kind of telling
on yourself.
That's like saying,
"Since murder is illegal,
can I assume you don't want
to go out on my boat?"
[ Laughter ]
According to new research,
dogs can be more effective
at detecting the coronavirus
than standard PCR tests,
but they're a lot less gentle
with the swabs.
[ Laughter ]
Did a really nice job
with that one.
I didn't know what it was
going to look like.
I'll admit, in my head,
I thought they'd be holding
the swabs in their paws,
but that's what makes this show
so much fun to do.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
according to new research,
dogs can detect coronavirus
with up to 94% accuracy.
Cats, too.
They just won't tell you.
[ Laughter ]
Retailer Dick's Sporting Goods
today launched its own line
of men's athletic apparel,
but it's been a little awkward
for the employees.
"Let's see what we have
out back.
What's your Dick's size?"
[ Laughter ]
Scollins.
[ Fresh laughter ]
I mean, I know we can't resist,
but, fundamentally,
the joke makes no sense.
[ Laughter ]
Like when you ask for a pair
of khakis at The Gap,
they don't say,
"What's your Gap's size?"
[ Laughter ]
It's a store.
They don't have different sizes.
You don't have to know your size
for that store.
Not like the metric system.
And, finally,
according to a new study,
people are not good
at judging when
to end a conversation,
or when to start one.
[ Laughter ]
You know what he's asking him?
"What's your Dick's size?"
[ Laughter ]
The store!
You can't beep me
if it's a store.
I'm going to have to watch
to see if I got beeped.
And it's nice, because I almost
never have any reason to watch.
[ Laughter ]
Karen wrote that joke,
which is funny.
That means somebody here's
been talking to Karen
about what goes on
in the men's room.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Today was St. Patrick's Day,
though, this year,
Dr. Fauci recommends wearing one
of these, instead.
The Biden administration
has announced
that the national vaccine
availability website,
vaccinefinder.gov,
is scheduled to go live
on May 1st,
so make sure to check it
on May 7th, when they get it
back up and running.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump,
last night, called in
to Fox News host
Maria Bartiromo's show
and encouraged all Americans
to get the vaccine.
Trump said getting the vaccine
was the best thing he ever
secretly did.
During an interview last night
on Fox News,
former President Trump said
that he is not a fan
of Duchess Meghan Markle
because of the way,
"She talks about the queen."
I must have missed that.
Meghan dissed Oprah
to her face?!
[ Laughter ]
Actor Elliot Page
recently became
the first transgender man
to be on the cover
of Time magazine.
Now, I know that term
may be unfamiliar to some,
so, for the uninformed,
a magazine
is a printed publication
containing articles and photos.
An ice cream company
in New Jersey
is reportedly facing more
than $230,000 in fines,
after two workers lost
a total of three fingers
while repairing a machine.
Even more concerning,
their new flavor...
[ Laughter ]
Ally.
Oh, Ally's eyes light up...
[ Laughter ]
...she reads a story like that.
A former Goldman Sachs
investment banker
recently purchased
the New York City mansion
that once belonged
to Jeffrey Epstein
for $51 million,
this according to a note card
in the "SVU" writers' room.
[ Laughter ]
Public health officials
confirmed yesterday
that the coronavirus variant
first detected in Brazil
has been found in Massachusetts.
The Brazilian variant
is just like the regular one,
but it looks like this.
[ Laughter ]
Wouldn't have expected Bryan
for that one.
There you go.
You learn a little bit more
about your writers every day.
Always more than I want to know.
[ Laughter ]
Dictionary.com
has recently added
"finna" and "supposably"
to its online database,
as in, "Supposably,
I'm finna stop using
dictionary.com."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
legalizing marijuana created
77,000 new jobs last year.
Or, put another way,
77,000 people forgot
to show up at their old jobs.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
it was announced yesterday
that Tiger Woods
will be featured
on the PGA 2K video game,
though, for obvious reasons,
he's being removed
from "Mario Kart."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ahead of yesterday's
virtual summit
between the prime minister
of Ireland and President Biden,
the Irish government
sent the White House
a traditional bowl of shamrocks
and we sent them the traditional
American gift --
a bouquet of Tomahawk
cruise missiles.
Former President Trump
is reportedly planning to sit
for 12 interviews
over the next few weeks
with authors writing books
about him.
Twelve books!
Harry Potter
didn't even get 12 books.
What's left to know?
"Oh, wow.
It says here that,
as a husband,
he was sub par."
Twelve Republican congressmen,
yesterday, voted
against honoring
law enforcement officers
who responded
to the Capitol siege
because they disagreed
with the bill's characterization
of the attack
as an insurrection.
Apparently,
they'd rather think of it
as an overbooked tour.
The NCAA March Madness
basketball tournament
began today,
and it's extra exciting
because there was
no tournament last year,
so this is my first chance
in two years to get furious
at 19-year-olds I hadn't
heard of five minutes ago.
Pass it, Johnson!
You're not a shooter!
Damn you,
Northeast Tennessee A&M!
The mayor of Lyon, France,
recently caused an outrage
after he announced
that school menus
would no longer include meat,
which means those poor kids
will have to switch
to white wine.
[ Laughter ]
Today was Awkward Moments Day,
this news first reported
by the guy who's actually
waving to the person behind you.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
the goat population
of a town in North Wales
has experienced a sharp rise
after officials were unable
to provide contraceptives
to the goats,
due to the pandemic,
and it's been really hard
on the kids.
♪♪
[ Whistling and applause ]